how's gum breads money and welcome to
five weird stuff online
oh boy oh boy do we have some amazing
items for you brothers today number four
it's gonna be so cool
I might am i click baiting my own video
Jesus Christ
first item tiny man's tricks up your
sleeves hi how's it going brother
hi half gone bras pulling fire here put
it back here
welcome to fight what are you doing
what are you doing alright every episode
every goddamn episode it looks like I
need to change my outfit I like how this
is normal for the PewDiePie channel just
a regular photo pie video right here
how's it going everyone it looks
beautiful
can I touch your face come here put your
face on the screen let me touch you
I'll put your butt put your butt on the
screen right now yes
item number through whatever it's a
wankum style its Gangnam style but he's
wanking it's funny because he has a
penis photographer hilarious
all right so the fourth item
I'm only already wearing see if you can
spot it all right so the final item of
this week is gonna be presented by Edgar
what it's basically uh it's not a big
deal or anything but it's a boob baking
mold so I thought we were gonna make
some titties
so yeah let's go all right guys welcome
to cooking with Edgar
so you take your books and black form
like this first you want to grab your
ingredients and [ __ ] think they're over
here yeah they're definitely in here
right you grab your milk and your
cooking I mean and your cooking thing
then you grab your bowl all right so
first you empty of the [ __ ] into the
bowl I'm controlling PewDiePie
genetically it's not cocaine 100% all
right and then you add the milk and [ __ ]
and then you mix that [ __ ] together
and yeah no no no real good
cocaine titties my favorite alright then
you add the sugar or just watch someone
else add the sugar all right so now it's
time to cook that [ __ ] on the stone holy
[ __ ]
you pour them the cocaine mix into the
bowl then you make your peasant do all
this dairy as you can tell the peasant
has stirred it well because it's nice
and creamy just like your mom said
alright then you take your your kids and
you pour them in the taste alright so
there you go our titties are ready now
we just need to wait three hours and
their refrigerator
alright pros our titties are now
complete oh god they're not let's just
empty them in the Jesus Christ I smell
good Nate again oh my god I can't help
myself I honestly don't know how deep it
is
hey what's this do a good old oh my god
better
that's one nipple damn it again you're
making this so hard this is my cooking
show I do whatever the [ __ ] that wall Oh
they almost feel like real titties now
there's one more detail that needs to be
finished
and now your altar is complete you can
choose whatever enemy [ __ ] you want
I chose sakura-chan I'm so ready to
[ __ ] show my ass up in these titties
I pray to you sakura-chan I pray to you
every night when will you notice me I
will now feast on your beautiful titties
Thank You sakura-chan thank you so much
all right friends I hope you enjoyed
this episode thank you so much for
hitting that like button all the support
for this show has just been amazing so
far I really love making these it seems
like your brothers really love them as
well so keep leaving your suggestions to
me a whip through it fit five words
stuff online and I'll see you brothers
in the next one as always stay awesome
friends
[ __ ] care of your brain you ready yes
yeah it's me prototype you recognize me
they look like I'm about to molest my
dog